um so thanks uh everybody for coming
back to the last talk of the day
um let me again uh take an opportunity
i think we don't thank the guys behind
the
camera often enough i very much want to
thank
all the support we've been getting from
omid and jesse and
others and also the semester long
organizers um thanks thanks everybody
and
we've given some reminders so after this
uh
lecture there's a reception so please
join
the gather town location and
we can chat in a more leisurely way
it's uh my real pleasure to introduce my
colleague constituent takamiro
georgia tech he's going to talk about
some recent
very sharp results with
pierre joseph on sharp point curry and
lock civil inequality
so-called switch chain on regular
bipartite graphs
thank you thank you for the introduction
okay so
i designed the presentation to be
very friendly so i will start with some
basic definitions
so the
the object of this result
is uh the set of the regular bipartite
graphs simple graphs but uh for future
we will need
i will need the definition of
multi-graph
because i will consider uh
sort of in parallel the configuration
model it will be important
so uh the regular bipartite multi graph
on the set of vertices we have n
vertices on the left and vertices on the
right
we connect every vertex on the left to
d vertices on the right so that the
degree of
every right vertex is d as well so this
will be the object
if the graph doesn't have multi edges
it's called simple and we will have
these two this notation
this omega n of d
i don't know if you see when i select
the text
so this this is the
set of simple apartheid graphs and
omega n with a superscript
capital c configuration model i will
discuss this later
we'll denote multi graphs
the multiplicity will be denoted by
mult of at the edge and
uh uh one
small thing as the adjacency matrix
signature i will
really need this but the the adjacency
matrix
will be viewed as m by n matrix for
for for such graphs instead of
2 n by 2 n so formally we'll have 2 n
vertices
but we can always reduce
the matrix by removing the
um the zeros the
uh zeros on the uh uh
of the two minors consistent of zero so
uh it will be n by n so
here is an example if i if i have a
multi graph on uh
four left and four right vertices here
is the corresponding
adjacency matrix you see here we have a
single multi edge going from vertex left
vertex 3 to right vertex 4.
okay so uh next definition is of
simple switching so uh
we can define uh an operation
for uh for transforming
a deregular graph we start with
bipartite multi multi-graph
and pick two edges
i1 j1 and i2 j2 such that multiplicity
of both edges
is non-zero so uh the two
left vertices i1 and i2 are distinct and
the same for the two right vertices
then uh we uh define the simple solution
operation on these edges
as uh operation of replacing the
original edges with
i1 j2 and i2 j1
so we just swap the
you can view this process as swapping
the
end points of the edges keeping the same
initial points i1 and i2 you swap
the the endpoints and this is the formal
definition
it's just the transformation of
multiplicities
uh we we have decrease in multiplicities
for
four hsi1 j1 and i2 j2 and we add
multiplicities to
i1 j2 and i2 j1 everything else remains
the same
here is an example of the simple switch
again i start with the same multi graph
on the left and then i i pick two edges
and then i just switch the
right end points of these two edges and
you see what is the corresponding
operation on the adjacency matrix we
just move
uh one so this two
is decomposed it's a multi edge so one
is moved
to to this positions three three
and one at the top is moved to the
position two four
okay so we have now our objects
the operation for traveling on the
apartheid graphs
now we can define what the switch markov
chain is
so we have this space
either it's simple we partake graphs or
multi graphs
and then we define in both cases we
define the switch markov chain
as follows so given a graph we pick two
edges independently uniformly at random
and you see if we have ordered pair of
edges we have nd times and d minus one
choices
so if the edge has a non-trivial
multiplicity we pick this edge according
to its multiplicity so the number of
choices is always the same
and then if the edges are not incident
in case of the multi graphs we uh
move then we do simple switching on
these edges
and a move to the obtained to the new
obtained multi graph
in the simple case in the case in the
case of the space of simple graphs
we require additionally that um not only
the edges are not incident we require
that the simple switching operation on
this edges does not introduce multi
edges
if it does not then we again move to the
to the next graph
uh otherwise state the same graph g
so this is the definition of this of the
chain of the markov process
and uh so for the simple
the apartheid graphs it can be shown
that the stationary measure is uniform
uh for the switching on the multi graphs
the stationary measure is not is not
uniform you see it
it depends really on multiplicities
of edges in the graph so we have here
this
uh factor in the denominator which
is the product of multiplicities of the
edges of g
and uh here zero factorial is one
the standard convention so both chains
are reversible
uh this is just a useful observation for
the future
so we have this reversibility condition
here p subscript s and p
subscript c are corresponding transition
matrices
for the simple graphs and for the
configuration models that i'm going to
discuss soon
okay so next i just want to uh
to to set up the notation uh
it is a general roster and we have
reversible reducible markov chain on
fine state space omega
transition distribution p sorry
stationary distribution p transition
matrix p uh so
by reversibility we know that
eigenvalues are real
uh we will order them in the
non-increasing order
and then we will define the relaxation
time
as the inverse of the absolute spectral
gap
and the mixing time as the first
uh the first time when
the total variation distance uh
between the stationary distribution and
the
uh distribution of this step of
the chain given some initial initial
state omega
is less than one quarter where this
maximum is taken overall
so i will consider only mixing time with
the with this
one quarter fixed without considering
epsilon mixing
so we have the standard relation
which partially justifies why the
relaxation time
is interesting can be interesting
okay so next is
also general observation connection of
the notion of relaxation time to upon
carry inequalities
so again if we have irreducible
reversible markov chain
uh with a mark of generator q
which is transition matrix minus
identity we say it satisfies upon
current inequality for every function
from the state space omega to r we have
this inequality the variance of f is
bounded by
this local uh local fluctuations of f
with appropriate weights so where we use
the generator question um
yes i'm sorry could you explain what is
pt it's a distribution at time t of
what distribution of what are you
looking at i just
completely don't know so at the previous
slide you mean
yep uh it's a previous slide it pt
is uh the uh so it is
uh pt of omega is the distribution which
encodes the transition probability so it
is a
transition after uh after t steps
given initial state omega so
0 is equal to omega then uh
conditions on x 0 equal omega you have
some conditional distribution of
x t x t is the t
element of this chain yes this element
of the stochastic process
so the distribution of this this element
on the state space omega
is usually denoted like this so
okay i don't quite understand what
random elements
you don't have any random elements
uh but here there is no random elements
it's just comparison of distributions
you have distribution of x
t and you have stationary distribution
just comparison of probability mass
functions
okay yeah galena just think of
p to the t the matrix p raised to power
t
applied to uh whatever distribution you
started it could be
and the transition matrix is just
between the adjacency adjacency matrices
just like whatever no it is transition
matrix of of
the chain so it is a probability
the ij's element is the probability of
going from i state to j
state and the state is what the
adjacency matrix
the state is the graph or if you want to
use the
yes it's adjacency matrix yes if you
want
okay so uh
so returning to pancar inequality uh
there is a standard computation which
tells that uh the best constant
the best constant alpha in the palm car
inequality so sometimes the constant is
put
on the left hand side but here it's
well let's put it here on the right hand
side of the inequality then it's just
the relaxation time so it's the same
thing
um so uh instead of studying relaxation
time we will
just consider uh the one car inequality
just a matter of notation
okay so now finally i can state what the
problem is
the problem is what is the relaxation
and mixing time of the switch mark of
chain on simple departure irregular
graphs
why this question can be interesting so
if
this this is a natural model for for
graphs
or maybe a undirected irregular graphs
are
more natural and more uh often used but
departed regular
model is also uh important and
uh the switch markov chain is a standard
way to generate random uniform random
simple the regular graph you start with
arbitrary graph
you run this markov chain for some
number of steps
and then if you have a bound on the
mixing time you know
after how many steps your resulting
graph will be almost uniformly
distributed
so if the mix if you are able to have a
strong bound on the mixing time
you will be able to say that after
relatively small number of steps
you will generate a uniform uh
or almost uniform uh department
irregular graph
this problem of uniform or almost
uniform generation of this graph is
is actively studied because although
this is a natural model it's not it's
not that easy to
generate and uh there are open problems
about optimal algorithms for generation
uh
especially in the dance version
so this is the the problem and uh here
is the conjecture
that uh for d between three and then
over two uh
the relaxation time should be of order
nd and the mixing
of order and d log that
okay so this is the conjecture this this
is the question i'm going to start
okay
now uh before stating uh our main result
uh i need to say a few words about the
configuration model
so uh before i introduce to this
state space omega n superscript c
the state of the state space of multi
graphs
and uh we have uh the switching
i just uh here repeat the definition of
the switch
chain for the state space here is the
generator of the switching it can be
easily computed but
the stationary distribution is
is the distribution that i already
described so this
this formula here so okay
so uh how we can interpret
this markov chain in fact there is a
very nice
uh way to to view this uh
random process a very nice
interpretation which
does not exist in the simple case but
let's consider the
this case of multi graphs
so the distribution uh the stationary
distribution corresponds to
so called configuration model of
randomness on the set of multi graphs
departed multi graphs
here is how the configuration model is
is obtained so instead of considering n
left and
and right vertices we consider n left
buckets
each bucket contains d points and and
right buckets so
here in this picture the degree d
is two and n is equal to four
so we have all together eight points on
the left and at eight points on the
right
then uh the uh imagine that we consider
uniform a perfect matching of left
vertices with right vertices
and uh after that after we define this
we generate this uniform uniform perfect
matching we
sort of compress back the buckets to the
vertices
so this is what we get in the in this
particular example
so the graph the multi graph that we
obtained in this way will be distributed
according to this measure p
sub subscript c the measure that i
uh defined on the previous slide here
okay so this is the configuration model
the
advantage of this interpretation is that
you can relate generation of
you can relate uniform random perfect
matchings
here on the left of this picture to
the uh to just uh considering a
random uniform permutations of nd
elements
and moreover the switching operation on
this
perfect matching will then correspond to
the transposition
operation for the permutation this way
you have
a straightforward correspondence between
the switch chain on multi-graphs and the
transposition
chain for on the set of permutations of
nd elements
so this is what uh yeah what i just said
and this correspondence allows to
to compute the mixing time and
relaxation time
basically you don't compute you just say
that uh
the mixing time and relaxation time is
bounded by corresponding quantities for
the
transposition uh transposition work
on the set of permutations and those
results are
old known results from the literature so
here is
the uh the statement
for the transposition chain on
permutations uh
optimal bound for the pancara constant
is known and for the
for for luxo believe for mixing time it
is known as
the result due to diacones and uh
and uh once you have this result
it is very easy to relate uh the
um this to the
corresponding quantities for the switch
chain on multi graph so this is the
claim
one carry constant of switch markov
chain on multi graphs is of order
md so the conjecture if you recall the
conjecture that i stated before
for the simple graphs for multi graphs
it is uh
well given known results in the
literature it's triviality
and also the mixing type of order nd log
so there is nothing really to work on
okay but this argument that does not
care to switch in on simple graphs
because of
this problem uh when we switch in the
simple graph setting we should
always
consider the possibility of
introducing multi edges so we will
prohibit moves that introduce multi
edges
and uh sort of we can use this
as uh some some work we can also use
this as some work on perfect matchings
but not all perfect machines only
results will
which correspond to simple apartheid
graphs
and then some of the solution will will
be prohibited so there is no
there is no correspondence to the
transposition the transposition model
for
for permutation
so here are some uh results from the
literature so i must
say that uh the literature is is
so there are numerous results a lot of
results but
um i would say that most of them deal
with the
undirected model rather than bipartite
model so here i
mentioned two results from the bipartite
bipartite model
so uh result due to kanan the italian
vampire
the mixing time of the switch chain on
the bipartite
graphs here is the estimate which
comes it was not stated in this form in
the paper
uh so the that paper dealt with the
question whether this chain is rapidly
mixing
and what the authors proved is that
yes the chain uh the switch chain on
departure simple graphs is rapidly
mixing so
this is just an explicit dependence on n
and d
that uh pierre and i
traced traced in the argument and uh
here is
also explicit dependence on nnd with
some
variation of the argument uh in another
paper by dire green hill
clear rosen stone
so a lot of papers dealing with
undirected setting
setting of directed graphs graphs with
predefined degree sequences
so here i mentioned some authors were
working on that
or who worked on that before but uh i
would say that
the direction the primary direction now
although it's very active
is still rather about
proving that the chain is rapidly mixing
rapidly
rapid mixing means that the mixing time
is bounded by uh
by a poly logarithm of the state space
from above so it is more in the
in this direction so uh very general
uh uh setting
uh very weak assumptions on the degree
sequences
but as an outcome
rather suboptimal estimates of the
mixing time you see here even here the
powers of
n d are really huge
okay the result for perfect matchings
uh can you remind me that's they they
proved that just by
uh they just calculate the
representations
uh uh yes but i i i didn't really
go into details yes it's uh it was
something like that yeah
i did i didn't read that paper in detail
okay
um also there is uh yeah i'm trying to
remember so this can also be
seen the simple graph case as
given the
row and column sums uh i see
maybe not for the switching all i wanted
to say was
the there was a byproduct of jerome
sinclair
uh the girder result right right maybe
this is what james lee was talking about
perfect matchings of bipartite graphs
i think as a pipe as a byproduct they
showed it is possible to sample
um from simple graphs given the degree
sequences
yeah but it's not about switching
yes yes this is as i also should mention
that yeah this is actually what
mentioned here so
the there are other methods apart from
the switching other methods of
generation
of uniform uniform graphs irregular and
modular models yes not using the switch
chain
there are even methods for exact uniform
generation
assuming some some assumptions on the on
the
degree if the degree is not too large
there are
fast and uh very efficient methods yes
but here we just work with the switching
okay so another thing before i state our
result
uh is uh because because this will be uh
important in the last part of my talk uh
the canonical pass method
it is used in a lot
of results dealing with this particular
model the switching
here is just some example of the
canonical pass method i wanted to give
some example it's not it's not the only
possible uh
way to uh to
there are many variations but here just
let's see
how it goes we have some reversible
reducible markov chain
say with uniform stationary distribution
i just give an example there are more
general results
so for each pair of state states we
choose
some paths connecting x to y for each
pair of states x and y
and then we can define this quantity
which
can be interpreted so this sum here
uh the sum and the brackets can be
interpreted as some
some way of measuring the length of the
path
and the summation is taken over all
paths
containing the edge from i to j
so now we take the maximum and we
normalize
by the cardinality of the state space
and then there is this classical
estimate
that the second eigenvalue of the
transition matrix is bounded from above
by
one minus one over cup with cup defined
this way
so the idea is the following if you you
are able to
uh to construct uh for this canonical
path in such a way that no edge is
reused too many times
then you are able to to get an efficient
estimate on
lambda 2 and some lower bounds on lambda
n are also
available i just didn't write them here
so you will be able to
to estimate the absolute uh spectral gap
and so the relaxation time
okay canonical pass plays some role in
our argument but it's sort of a part of
the argument not
no not the main point
okay so yes here is just uh some
remarks that just apply and say this
statement to
our problem of course it doesn't doesn't
give the optimal the optimal bound on
one car constant that we want
okay so
finally i'm able to state the result
you see we have the assumption on d we
really worked hard to
to allow d grow to infinity was n it was
our
intention to to make the result work in
this setting as well
but still upper bound you see we have a
very small power of n as an upper bound
for e
so we have these assumptions on
parameters now the
statement is that provided that d
satisfy this condition the switch markov
chain
on a simple irregular graph satisfies
one car inequality
with the constant of order nd
with a constant of order nd
this is just explicitly written upon
current quality here
so uh the uh
the restriction of g we did not optimize
but it's uh
clear that in our argument it cannot be
uh
it cannot be pushed to to say
anything close to one so we definitely
have some
some uh absolute threshold when our
argument
fails it i think it's something around
either one third or one half so
above that we our argument really
doesn't work
but some improvement is possible
so and uh yes the balance is optimal the
the point constant is is really of order
nd
and this can be checked by considering
this simple function you just
uh define f of
of graph g equal to one if the edge
one one if one to one is an edge in g
yes first left vertex to first right
vertex is an h and g and zero otherwise
and you can check that with this
function you really have this nd
multiple
okay so
okay let me just i i want to see how
many times how much time is left
uh okay the approach
the approach is based on comparing this
to this
to the configuration model we compare
the switch chain on simple the part type
graphs to the configuration mode
so how to compare
just note that d goes to infinity and
we can go to infinity in our setting so
we cannot
even claim that the
total measure of this set of simple
graphs
in the configuration model is proper is
is sort of does not go does not go to
zero
so the the measures
p sub configuration and the uniform
measure
on the simple graphs really are
incomparable in austerity
so okay so
uh assume for a moment that
uh for every function from simple graphs
to r we can construct
a function f tilde from the
from the multi graphs to r satisfies the
following condition
first the variance of f is less than
some absolute constant times variance of
f
with respect to corresponding
corresponding stationary distributions
and second condition is for the directly
forms
so suppose that the directly a form of f
tilde is bounded by the directly form of
f for some universal constant
then we would get the result because we
know that
the variance of f tilde is bounded by nd
times the corresponding quadratic form
of f tilde
and then we will just have this sequence
of three inequalities which
will give us that variance of f is less
than some
multiple of nd times times the quadratic
form of this claritic form for f so
this is this is our intention to
construct this function ft till then but
by itself this this this is of course
this is nothing it's just uh
our best wishes to to find this function
ft or the the question is
whether this function exists at all and
if so
even if so how to construct it
question is the first step
where your assumption on the degree
comes or also in both steps because the
two distributions are quite different
could be different based on
multiple cities the n to the one over
one thousand that you mentioned
uh yes the distributions can be
different
yes but uh still do you agree that if we
have this
to conditionally satisfy themselves okay
but i was curious i guess i shouldn't
jump ahead
whether you need that assumption on the
degree
in both parts or only one
ah i think more important
is the bound for directly forms
this is really most the heaviest part of
the argument and where we
we we need very strong assumptions for
the variance i i don't remember exactly
but
definitely assumptions are milder for
the variance
thanks
okay okay so
uh this is this is some small remark
about the harmonic extension so you see
the second requirement on f tilt
uh we need the nuclear form of ftl to be
bounded by the nuclear form of f
uh it suggests that the quadratic form
this is directly a form for ftl should
be small
okay whenever you so if you
want a nuclear form of your auxiliary
function to be small
it seems natural to consider the
harmonic extension
so we start with a function f which is a
function on simple graphs yes we've used
then this set of simple graphs
as a boundary
of the of the extension field
so uh just define the harmonic extension
so this is the definition the formal
definition of the harmonic extension
uh it is it equals to the original
function f1 omega n of d
and otherwise it satisfies this this
condition
and there is also uh some probabilistic
more explicit expression
for uh f sub h
so the question is if harmonic extension
can be used in this context
so there is a problem with the harmonic
extension
because it can be checked that
in the regime d go into infinity you can
construct example of the function f such
that its harmonic extension satisfies
this so the variance of the harmonic
extension of f
with respect to the configuration to the
stationary measure on the configuration
model
is little law of the variance of the
original function
and recall that originally we want both
conditions to be satisfied
we want both the variance of uh
f tilde to majorize variance of f
and at the same time the directly a form
of f tilde to be dominated by the
directly form of f
so this well you just showed us this
this just holds because
you can find the multi graphs that are
very far from every
simple graph and they're you know and
then just make the function large there
make the function zero on simple graphs
so then the extension will have very
small variance is that
i should i don't remember really what
the example is but
i would say something something
like something like this you you should
define
a function f which sort of oscillates
locally
but on the global scale it remains of
the same order
uh and then if you define the the
harmonic extension of this function
this averaging procedure will kill local
oscillation
and the harmonic extension will be
almost constant
i will discuss this problem we will have
the same problem with our approach
as well but yes i think this is the
construction
okay so now i'm going to describe
what the construction of the function
extension is
so uh some there is some reduction which
i don't want to go into it some
technical details but
in our assumption on d you really
shouldn't bother about
uh multi graphs we which have multi
edges of multiplicity is real great
because the probability is very small
really we should care about multi graphs
which have only multiplicity 2
edges there are some other
some other technical assumptions that
that are important
okay so here uh what we do we start by
defining
this object called s neighborhood s for
simple stands for simple
we start with multi graph g prime
and then for this multi graph uh so
we uh pick its multi edges so this
isjs is is this set the collection of
multi edges of this graph of
multiplicity tool yes
we agreed that multiplicity 3 we don't
consider and greater
so suppose there are k edges like this
so then we define a path on
the configuration model the path of
length k
we say that the pass is simple if um
uh okay so here is some technical
condition but basically what
uh what this condition says is that at
each step
you apply simple solution operation to
destroy this multi
one of the multiplicity two edges okay
say if you start with k
multiplicity two edges in the graph g
prime then after k steps
you destroy all of them and you get a
simple graph
in fact there are some additional
technical assumptions but for this talk
let's just assume that
that's everything we want just to
destroy all multi edges
and to to get to a simple graph this way
we
sort of get to the closest possible
simple graphs
of course you can destroy multi-edge in
many way in many ways
right you you can pick uh kind of the
the other edge you switch with there are
many choices
so you will get actually a lot of simple
paths
leading from this graph g prime so we
have many simple paths of length k
and uh the set of all endpoints of this
simple path will be
called the s neighborhood simple
neighborhood of the graph g prime
so roughly speaking it is the set of all
nearby simple graphs
okay so now i
i will need this function so this is
just the averaging over s
over s neighborhood so for each
uh for each multi oh i'm sorry that uh
i i should really use different notation
so
uh this g prime now plays a role of g so
okay the point is that this this is an
averaging over s neighborhood for every
multi graph
you define this function h of the multi
graph
as the average of the original function
f over the
s neighborhood of this multi graph
okay so this is some preliminary
construction
okay so now this function h
provides uh sort of
some part of the of the extension f teal
that we need
each sort of plays the role of the
harmonic extension but it is better
for us because it's easier to work with
maybe if i have time i will comment
in the end uh why we use this notion of
s neighborhood instead of just picking h
to be the harmonic extension of f
but the same problem as with harmonic
extension h by itself does not
does not work as the valid extension f
tilde because
because it's varianced it's okay it's
directly a form can be nice but its
variance is not nice it can
it can be very small so
in order to uh construct extension with
the right variance
we introduce controlled fluctuations to
the function h so how we do this we
start with auxiliary gaussian field so
our construction will be randomized
so we construct an auxiliary gaussian
field on the
on this configuration model the field
satisfying
uh all of this property so let's see
so we have a function with fixed from
the beginning function f
on the set of simple graphs and now we
construct the gaussian field
on the set of multi-graphs yes the
the set of gaussian variables indexed by
the
collection of multi graphs so centered
variance of each uh component is equal
to one
and now there are two more conditions
which are sort of contradictory to each
other
the first condition tells us that for
any adjacent graphs
multi graphs the covariance of
of these gaussian variables is large so
here i put
some uh constant d over n and this is
what we use in the paper but please
don't pay
too much attention d over n does not
really play much role here
there is some some room for changing the
constant there is some
valid range for for choosing this
concept for which the construction works
just view it as the statement that the
covariance of
uh nearby variables is
huge is close to one so this is the
first condition
huge correlation the second condition uh
which is very technical and uh difficult
to read but
basically what what it means that uh
that the um the field should not be too
correlated so when we consider
this field on the global scale then uh
the variable say if we pick uh two
uh two graphs two graphs
uh typical graphs on uh
on omega and c
then uh these variables x i
of g one and x i of g two should be
almost uncorrelated
and here what is written here in
condition 3 is just the precise
statement of what exactly we want from
from these variables so
we want this complicated expression
which just appears in uh
uh in our bound of um
of the variance when we bound the
variance it is
this this condition becomes important
but
just uh just view it as the condition
that the field is not too
too correlated on the global scale okay
pick two typical multi graphs
uh xi of g1 and xi of g2 should be
almost uncorrelated
can you do this just by taking a a
field that's just take the gas like the
gaussian free field but grounded at
like a a random subset of vertices
so we uh yeah we we thought about using
gaussian free field but since we don't
have any experience with that we ended
up just
cooking up some uh
some amateur construction so no we don't
use gaussian free field but i'm sure
it's
it should be possible to use it yeah but
we just just constructed sort of uh
directly yeah i mean the gaussian free
field would be the one which maximizes
your
your variance subject to those
covariance conditions on adjacent
vertices that's why
yes probably probably something like
this will work but yeah so as i said we
just use we just used some
some some other
some other construction
it is also based on some randomness
arguments some average in argument
okay that's why i don't discuss why
why we know that this field exists
because i'm sure
we can just use some advanced theory
to to to show this very fast that such a
field exists so i just assume that
it is constructed now uh
suppose that uh we have a function yes
we
now defines its extension f tilt by the
following
rule so here i just uh to say in advance
i
meet some cases some technical cases
there are issues with some
uh some simple graphs which are not
contained in too many s neighborhoods
i should say are contained in very few s
neighborhoods so
there are also issues with the graphs
that have multiplicity
three or greater of edges so
some some marginal cases which i really
don't don't want to discuss here two
main cases
uh uh as are explained here
if g is simple then we just have f tilde
is equal to f
it should be an extension and if g
is the multi graph then first we define
local variation of f you see
what this expression here means is just
sort of local variance of f if you
consider uniform distribution on s
neighborhood of our
graph g because h we recall what
how h was defined h is nothing but the
average
of the value of f over s neighborhood of
g
so we have f minus its average over s
neighborhood
and we sum up the squares and normalized
so this is just the variance with
respect to uniform distribution s
neighborhood
and now this is how we introduce this
controlled flotations
so we take uh f tilde to be g
to be this uh this average plus
uh x i of g this element of the
of the gaussian field times the the
deviation times this
local standard deviation
okay so
uh and uh okay yes so there are some
some special cases but essentially this
is how f tilde is constructed
so we have global
averaging sort of and
so we have we have a part which is
responsible for capturing global
fluctuation
of f and we have a part this part which
is responsible for capturing local
fluctuation of f
okay
so here is some some graphical
interpretation of what is going on
so this this controlled fluctuations
uh i needed for to treat the following
key so
uh image imagine that we have a function
f that
has large flag floatations on the local
scale but globally
remains constant so how we can generate
such a function
just assign say independent uh uniform
values to 0 1 or just independent
bernoulli variables
consider consider independent journal
variables attached to each graph
each simple graph then you will have a
function that on global scale is just
the same it's just the expectation of
this bernoulli variable
but locally it will have fluctuations of
order one so the variance of this
function will be of order one
this is this is how i graphically
represents hd function
but now if if you just try to define its
extension as
the averaging age as the average in our
s neighborhood
then uh this just kills the local
fluctuations and the variance
the resulting variance will be very
small so it's the same problem as
with harmonic extension but
this controlled fluctuations
with this parameters w of g they
actually resolve this problem
it turns out that they all this problem
here is the statement formal statement
summary of
what happens so if we have this function
we have this gaussian field satisfying
the
mentioned properties so we have ftill
there's a randomized extension
of f then with a positive probability
we have the two conditions that we that
we want to
confirm yes we have condition on the
variance
and at the same time we have condition
on the nuclear forms
and this basically this this implies
immediately implies
the right the right bound on the pawn
current constant
yes the bound on the variance is
guaranteed by the condition that
elements of the gaussian field are not
too correlated that what i said on the
global scale they
they are uncorrelated but uh the part of
the nuclear form
is possible because the elements of the
gaussian field are not
too uncorrelated you see here
we may encounters the opposite problem
because if we make this
size two correlated then uh
the fluctuation of our extension will be
too huge and the nuclear form just won't
be
we won't be able to estimate the
directive form in the right way
so there is sort of the these two
contradictory
uh conditions that uh that we
have to satisfy simultaneously and this
uh sort of
restricts restricts very very much the
uh our
choice for the for the construction for
the extension
okay so uh i see that i'm almost out of
time so i
unfortunately i will have to skip the
discussion of
how uh this uh
how we will go with with this with this
extension so there is some canonical
pass argument that
that is used partially and
um yes and uh here
uh to to to complete the talk here is
the
uh another statement that we get for
constant d
we are able to get optimal bound on the
logs of belief constant
and this basically follows the same
strategy
but the extension is simpler in this
case because in the constant regime we
don't have to worry
to worry about introducing the
controlled fluctuation so the
construction of the extension is
is much simpler
and uh yes we have uh
we have uh the this
bound n log n for the uh logs of belief
constant
uh which implies that
the for the constant d switch mark of
chain mixes in time
and log squared at most and the
conjectured value is m log n so we are
almost at the conjunction value but with
extra logo
okay so yeah this is everything i have
time for
thank you for that i have another
question the yeah for
for perfect matchings the mixing time is
sorry let me see you're i see for
perfect matchings the mixing time is
known to be correct right order nd
login like diagonal yes
and uh so well okay so now i can ask the
question you i mean
the way that they get that is actually
to analyze the entire spectrum of the
chain
using representation theory
uh so then i guess you i mean you could
con
i mean i guess
uh right so now for in your setting you
would be left to construct these f
tildes but now you would have to
construct entire subspaces of them
instead of just a single one
you know given a k-dimensional subspace
of s with a uniform bound on the
uh you know on the punch array constants
in that subspace you'd have to construct
the k dimensional subspace of f tildes
that would be the analog i guess
i'm just saying that and that would i
mean one suggestion to take off the lot
the extra love
yeah but another another thing is that
uh what we are working on now is to
consider modified log sobel for the
quality yeah yeah yeah we actually have
a have an idea
a working idea that that should give the
right bound and log n
because for the random transpositions
that's a softer way to get n log n
james you don't need the full spectrum
the full spectrum and login bound of
thai construction is great
because it bounced the l2 but to get
relative entropy and total variation you
can get away with
modified logs of subwoofer the log
symbol
unfortunately won't give because the
truth happens to be one over n log n
and so it gives the extra log yeah but
as he said if they
do the modified they could give yeah
great uh first of all thanks thanks
again uh
um so any other questions
comments and i do have a
grave confession and correction to make
but let me see anybody so
um yeah you know kosia thank you for
citing our results usually it's you know
it's a very nice gesture and kind to
quote one of the organizers um so
but i i had to go back and check on my
email
so you know over the years a couple of
people had complained that there was a
mistake in our paper the one with
uh ravi khanna and santa s
yeah and at least for the deregular case
i thought everything was good but as it
appears apparently
theorem 4.1 to be precise in our
paper was incorrect uh the way we go
from
bipartite graphs to perfect matchings
and back
you know there was a mistake um
catherine greenhill who's an expert on
this topic among other things is writing
a nice survey paper
uh and so she contacted us recently to
see you know how exactly to phrase this
um
so yeah so anyway for people listening
in it's
certainly better to appeal to the other
result
santosh tells me he and i at some point
uh you know in the last 10 years figured
out how to fix what we had done for the
d regular craze
but i don't clearly i don't remember
anything and nothing appears in print
yeah i see so
any other questions
comments and i checked uh the draft of
catherine's article and she included
certainly
your recent results in that yeah so
something to look forward to
so before i forget again we've
made various announcements so thanks to
omid
you don't even have to leave the room
pretty much you just click on what he
posted
in the chat how to get together town
where there's a reception now
with of course byob
thank you